Angelina Jolie attends the state dinner
with her eldest son Maddox I'm so proud
of him I'm so excited I feel like my
world expands as their World Experience
yeah I learned so much from them the duo
looked Chic as ever for the event on
Wednesday hosted by President Joe Biden
and first lady Jill Biden at the White
House honoring the president of South
Korea that's Angie rocking a vintage
Chanel jacket and a dress that was made
for her years ago along with her
personal jewelry Maddox looked Dapper in
a YSL tux and Cartier ring the dinner
marked the 70th anniversary of the U.S
and Republic of Korea Alliance which is
critical to advancing peace stability
and prosperity for the two countries the
indo-pacific and around the world now a
source tells E.T why Asia America
relations are important to Angelina's
family she and her children have had
close ties to the region including South
Korea for many years and Angie and
Maddox were honored to attend the state
dinner I felt very very lucky the Oscar
winner has visited South Korea many
times for her humanitarian and Refugee
advocacy over the past two decades and
she visited South Korea in 2019 while
dropping Maddox off for his first year
of college at yonsei University in Seoul
to study biochemistry what was very
beautiful is the way everybody said
goodbye when you know that your kids
love each other and you see the way they
all without any kind of prompting or
pushing
give each other notes hug each other
take care of each other support each
other then you feel like they're going
to be okay and they're going to always
have each other and Angie said the whole
experience had her deep in her Mom feels
I do know is the one moment in my life I
think I turned around six times before
like the airport just kind of you know
to just
you know and he's sweetly stayed and
kept waving it's nice to know that he
knows how much he's loved the actress
and Mom of six adopted Maddox from an
orphanage in Cambodia when he was seven
months old I'm so happy for him that
he's grown up into such a such a good
man and he's and I say that because he's
smart and he's doing his work but he's
also wild and so he's he's balanced in
his in his teenage uh years of course
Angie also shares 19 year old packs 18
year old Zahara 16 year old Shiloh and
14 year old twins Knox and Vivian with
her ex-husband Brad Pitt I'm so lucky
that we we've all been used to being
tied together for a long time and it was
so nice when Matt came home from college
and I think when you have that many
children they they really take care of
each other they are an amazing team so
I'm very very fortunate Wednesday's
appearance comes months after Angelina
step down from her role with the United
Nations where she also served on the
high-profile un High Commissioner of
refugees special Envoy after more than
20 years at the time Angie said in a
post on Instagram that refugees are the
people she admires most in the world and
she is dedicated to working with them
for the rest of her life I will be
working now with organizations led by
people most directly affected by
conflict that give the greatest voice to
them
[Music]
thank you